IVAN NARDINI: Hi, everyone, and
welcome to the Google IO 2022.
I'm Ivan Nardini.
I'm a Customer Engineer
at Google Cloud,
and today I want to
tell you a story.
That story begins with you, who
just joined the data science
team of an important
banking company.
Congratulations, now your team
is part of the data office,
and is responsible for
building innovative solutions
across several business units.
On day one Maya, the product
manager of the Fraud Detection
System, has a meeting
with you and your team.
She shows a rules-driven
engine composed
of a set of if/then,
else statements,
and logic are coded by
SMEs in collaboration
with the software
engineering team.
For each transaction,
she said that if it
comes from the country
X, and the cardholder
has several requests
within the last hour
with a certain amount,
then the system must
assign a fraud score of 0.95.
With that, Maya
had some concerns
about the main challenges
of the actual system.
First of all, human rules
are biased by definition.
They represent a
subjective component,
since different experts design
rules in different ways.
Secondly, the system is
hard to scale because rules
are required to be hard-coded.
Each time a new fraud pattern
is discovered by investigators,
the team needs to
manually express it
as if/then, else statements,
and integrate them.
Last but not least, it
also is hard to contain.
Indeed, we ended up
with [INAUDIBLE] rules,
each of them for
each fraud scenario.
And its maintainers are
investigators and software
engineers that tend
to come and go,
bringing with them
information about how
rules make the system.
So because of those
challenges, Maya
expressed the needs of
building a new system.
She wants to implement a modern
data-driven fraud detection
engine.
And because the company
is going to have
a process of digital
transformation,
she asked you and your team
to design it on Google Cloud.
She wants a machine
learning model
to estimate the probability of
each transaction to be a fraud.
She expects that the
model does not require
any manual intervention.
And it needs to be
interpretable at the same time
in order to allow her SME
and investigators to validate
its results and, if
necessary, improve it.
As I said, you are
part of the team that
has been assigned
to design and build
the system on Google Cloud.
So my question is, where
would you start from?
Well, I'm a customer engineer.
That's my job, and
I spend my time
talking with data science teams.
And I notice that the model
and its associated technology
tend to be seen
as a shopping list
without considering the
impact of their requirements
and dependencies on
the entire system.
Also, it happens sometimes
that phases like the model
experimentation tend to drive
choices about its components
and how they should work.
But the thing is that
building machine learning
models is just one phase, and
it has nothing automagical.
If you don't feed it
with good quality data,
it will not generate
good insights.
And if you don't
make it modular,
you will not able to adapt it
when new patterns of data come.
And this is just to say
that the model is important,
but sometimes the big
picture is missing.
And when you need to
production analyze your model,
when you need to make
it a product that
will generate business value,
well, the context matters most.
To build it, you need
culture and best practices.
That's why MLOps came out.
Indeed, the concept
itself expressed
the set of culture,
practice, and technology that
aim at unifying ML
development with operations
in order to put a
model into production.
At Google, we were able to
turn this concept concretely.
For example, one of the largest
production ML systems at Google
has thousands of ML models
training concurrently,
continuously retrained
with new data every hour,
and continuously deploying the
global serving infrastructure.
So we really know what MLOps
means, and as Google Cloud,
we want to share those expertise
and technology with you.
About the expertise,
you have people like me
that are ready to support you
in your ML journey day by day.
But talking about
technology, that's
the reason why we launched
Vertex AI, which is the Google
Cloud managed machine
learning platform
to help you accelerate
experimentation,
and deployment of
ML models at scale.
All you need to know is that the
platform has several building
blocks that allow you to
cover the entire lifecycle,
from data ingestion
to model training
all the way down to model
prediction and model
monitoring, in order to
production analyze your models.
So now that you have the
technology, the next question
is, what would be building
the new fraud detection
system on Vertex AI?
What will it look like?
How will it be better
compared to what you have?
Well, I already know the
answer to those questions.
Why?
Because I did it.
In collaboration with some of
my colleagues at Google Cloud,
we built Fraud Finder.
Fraud Finder is a project that
comes from some customer needs
to apply the state of the art
of data science and machine
learning to detect fraudulent
transactions at scale
in real time.
It's still a work in
progress, but me and the team
learned so many things along
the road that we thought,
why don't we share
our experience?
So here I am.
Are you with me?
Let's go on.
To build a simple
fraud detection system,
as Fraud Finder,
you start from data
of historical transactions.
Just to clarify in your
case, a transaction
is an event recorded
at 5:00 AM today,
associated with a customer
with a particular ID, who
made a payment of
a certain amount
to an identified merchant.
Now, part of that information
cannot be consumed either
by a model as they are.
In fact, the model needs
numbers, and only some of them
are numericals.
Also, you can think of applying
several data transformation
techniques to derive
new variables which
will be relevant to predict if
a transaction is a fraud or not.
Will the number of transactions
customers made recently matter?
What about the average
transaction amount
in the last week?
Could the terminal be
compromised for any customer
who is using it?
In other terms, you
define a set of features
to identify customer
spending behavior,
and characterize
the risk of fraud
associated with the terminals
over different time windows.
And you can do that
by using BigQuery,
which allows you to analyze
terabytes of data per second.
At that time, you
get your features
and you are ready
to train your model.
But let's consider some
aspects for a second.
First of all, in a real
time fraud detection system,
some of these features cannot be
calculated on the fly when you
serve the model.
How will you get
the average amount
of transactions over the last
three days in milliseconds?
You need a way to pass
them as inputs to the model
if you want to generate
online predictions.
Now, BigQuery is not engineered
for low latency reads.
That's why you need to
introduce and optimize
a data store for
lookup operations
at scale in low latency.
But there is another aspect
that needs to be highlighted.
In that real time system,
you have a high volume
of transactions you
can use to calculate
those features we keep floating
and collecting constantly
over time.
It implies that you'll
always get fresh data
to reconstruct features.
And depending on when
you decide to calculate
one feature or another,
you can end it up
with a set of features that
are not aligned in time.
For example, you
can keep calculating
the number of transactions
over the last three days.
Each day is at midnight,
but at the same time,
you will need to calculate the
average amount of transactions
over the last three hours
along the day several times.
And as you can imagine,
this has implications when
you need to train your model.
Indeed, when labels
become available,
those features will not be
aligned with them as well.
In your case, you will know if
a transaction is a fraud or not
only after some time.
The investigation is run and
validated your predictions.
Because of that, it
sounds incredibly
difficult to say
which set of features
contain the most up-to-date
historical information
associated with the label
you want to predict.
And when you are not
able to guarantee that,
the performance of your model
would be badly affected.
Because you serve
representative features
of the data and the label from
the field when the model goes
live.
So you need a way to get the
most up-to-date features,
you calculate over time before
the labels become available.
In other terms, you need
a time travel machine.
For your features, we
respect your labels.
For all those reasons
I just mentioned,
you may decide to introduce
a Feature Store, which
provides you a service that
help you to address data
leakage by providing
point-in-time lookups which
fetch the most up-to-date
features with respect
of the time labels
become availables.
And at the same time,
it serves those features
at scale with low latency,
as they were available
at training time, mitigating
the way possible training
and service queue.
So once you ingest the features
into the Feature Store,
you are ready to train
your model offline.
You fetch a sample of them,
aligned with the label,
into a notebook environment.
You use this sample
for running experiments
by defining different
training configurations
and tracking model
evaluation metrics.
And once you find the
best modeling approach,
you formalize the model training
as a pipeline component.
Then, you easily integrate that
component in machine learning
pipelines that
allow you to cover
all the steps required
to reproduce the model
training at scale.
And if, only if, the model
achieves certain threshold
levels in performance
metrics, then it
goes deploying to
serving environment,
for generating online
prediction when
a new request will require.
Notice how the Feature Store
passes the same aggregated
features you have calculated
offline to train the model
to produce online predictions.
In other terms, it solved
the training service
queue I mentioned so far.
All I showed you until
now, from Feature Store
to model training with
pipelines and the model serving,
can be implemented on Vertex
AI, which provides you
all those capabilities
by letting
you keep focusing on
your code and improving
the quality of your solution.
And talking about the solution,
let me show you what we got.
This is Fraud Finder, the
data application we worked on.
Once you pass some parameters
such as the Feature
Store, resource name,
and the endpoint ID,
you can start streaming
the transactions that
are generated for a
data synthesizer we
build in the backend.
After a while, if you
go in the Predict view,
you can see in yellow
the transactions that
were classified as a
fraud, with respect
to a particular
probability threshold.
And if you change it,
you can verify that fraud
becomes less frequent.
Lastly, under the
Dashboard view,
you have the Profile
of Latency, which
is represented by the
distribution of prediction
requests over a
fraction of a second.
As you can see, the back
end is doing a good job
if you consider that,
for each request,
it reads features from the
Vertex AI Feature Store.
It passes them into
Vertex AI endpoint
with transaction amount and
other variables from the field.
And the model
generates predictions
and return them back.
All this, thanks to Vertex AI.
About the rest, you also
have the distribution plot
of the fraudulent and
non-fraudulent transactions,
and you also have
some views showing
the active endpoints and the
model we have on Vertex AI.
OK, this was just
an example of what
you can achieve by leveraging
Vertex AI for MLOps.
We are at the end
of this journey.
To conclude, you
start from a system
that has biased because rules
were written by SMEs based
on their knowledge.
It was hard to
scale because rules
required to be hard coded.
It was hard to maintain because
of its all rules it generates.
And today, I showed you how
you can solve those challenges
with a simple fraud detection
system, which leverages
both data to train
machine learning models,
and Vertex AI platform to
production analyze them.
So now that you know that this
is possible, it's your turn.
Open the console and
start building and putting
your models into
production, using
Vertex AI on Google Cloud.
But don't forget one thing.
All I presented
today was possible
because different people
with different skills
and backgrounds decided to
join, work together, and learn
from each other as a team.
This is just to say
that machine learning is
a part of the picture.
And MLOps is about culture,
practice, technology,
but more importantly, people.
I hope you enjoyed the session.
Thank you and see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]